i love that
i love it i love it i got so many
thoughts
what's up reject nation we're gonna
watch today two
two little trailers here one for black
suit superman that came out yesterday
and another one for aquaman that came
out today i feel like they're going to
be
dropping one for each character at this
point right that's that's what the plan
must be
nope stop after aqua yeah
don't unite the rest of the league sorry
for being late to this guys all day
thursday
um starting from the early morning uh we
didn't stop filming and editing until
really late at night and then a couple
hours later it was one division
and then it was an all-nighter and
didn't take a nap until
like 4 p.m on friday schedule's a little
out of whack right now
lately i'm gonna probably take the
tomorrow off i want to check out the
black suit superman one and the aquaman
today
well we got some time let's do it people
just slap together
just drop them both in imovie and then
hit export of course you don't talk
about it afterwards
the whole world
is that kevin costner i think so yeah
i thought our journey foster in there
too you will help them
accomplish one does that get down or
shazam
oh look at it in the wind
flap flap
break that sound barrier clark
we're going to have to play that back
good got to make out a lot of voices
everyone was in there
i'm so happy about this
nice
yeah we're gonna play this back right
away right away back to one and of
course
encouraging you guys make a little
transcripts for us down below i'm gonna
be taking some guesses here but make
little transcripts down below will you
and also break down these suits that
we're about to look at
the whole world
i love that kevin costner saying that
yeah
that looks like lex's suit yeah
oh nice to hear russell crowe's voice
again
joerl
they wanted me back for a reason damn
straight they did
got more films in your contract
this movie's gonna show everyone why we
don't want henry cavill recast
[Music]
which i don't think that is the case i
will go into that later
dark
i love it i love it fighting the devil
and his army
in hell yes
yes right [ __ ] i got so many thoughts
i think it's important to watch these
twice especially the shorter ones
yeah because there's so much voices
overlapping that i'm like i'm looking at
the imagery but i'm also trying to keep
up with what's being said
i mean just some instant thoughts like
with the black suit superman clip
my main take i think that is cyborg
saying get down in the trailer
it sounds like get down or shazam at
first and i was like
but i don't think she's in this they're
gonna be random to throw in here
especially as a line of significance to
hype us up or something that would be
kind of distracting
but really like after my experience of
man of steel and bvs
uh recently clark's journey has been one
of its
learning to of acceptance having this
issue that
of what should i do while i'm here on
earth
being this alien and the situation and
the the complex dynamic he had with
pop kent and uh man of steel his dad
literally was like no don't say me don't
even
risk showing your powers i'm gonna let
myself die i don't think you know
jonathan kent intended it but you get
this psychological sense that he had
this sort of perhaps a little bit of
shame towards himself that he has to
hide this keep it a secret
even though that's not what jonathan
kent is intending i feel like that comes
through in the performance of henry
cavill and then of course like in batman
v superman
while he's trying to be a hero the media
just seems to keep slamming him and
there's people who just want to keep
taking him down
and then he's brought back here him
saying they wanted me back for a reason
i feel like having that line in here
does make a lot of people think
about all the news that's been coming
out as of late from my understanding
the bl not black suits from around but
black superman
is gonna be a separate like multiverse
thing i believe that's come out yeah
it's like from earth 32 or whatever
something like that is that just some
random number you guessed sean or is
that actual
research way to go buddy
let's do it but not instead of henry
cavill just with henrik
and yeah well he has this scene with his
dad
on top of the mountain and batman v
superman well it tells us like
learning lesson story of his past and to
hear jonathan kent say
fly son that's this arc again a full
circle story for superman oh yeah but
his dad
encouraging him to the fullest extent to
be who you have to be
be who you want to be yeah it makes your
heart he's the hero
yeah so the from where they were in the
troubling conflict they had especially
in jonathan kent's last moments to
getting this line of fly
sun now is beautiful to me absolutely
beautiful
and uh yeah i mean the suits are all
cool you guys can break them down and
tell what the hell they are i actually
don't know
but like one suit looks kind of like
lex's super power suit in the background
that's like my best guess
you got a zombie suit in there they look
like and then i love how he has the
option
for you know the og that is like blue
red suit
not not feeling today but the black suit
if i'm remembering
correctly helps sun absorption energy
yeah which is why he
uses that i think yeah cause i mean at
least in a long time since i've
read the depth of superman
science anyway yeah black is an
absorption color whereas like if you had
like a brighter colored suit it would
reflect more light off right right
that makes sense with aquaman what i'm
most curious about is
that aquaman movie that came
out which was really cool it was
definitely picking up after the events
of
justice league you know based off of the
amount they wanted to do and explore
here with him getting the trident
all these things like was some of what
is explored in that aquaman
solo movie actually done here first
yeah you know and is it going to be
recontextualized or will it fit in well
because it seemed like yeah i mean
obviously this movie was going to have a
lot of introduction to do
for aquaman and i have to imagine that
jack snyder's version of that is not
gonna be the same as josh's
so i guess what i would expect is more
multiversal sort of it's not gonna jive
with the current dc
right you know i love those images that
we got of
volkow in the snyder cut i i personally
prefer that look
at that like a long hair string now look
versus like
sleek ponytail man
[Laughter]
yeah definitely no you're absolutely
right about that jason mamoa is one of
the first people from the cast to just
publicly come out and just really talk
about how great the snyder cut is
they didn't want to go down the route of
casting a guy who looked like pacific
islander but that was zack snyder's
ideas x snyder was the one who found
jason momoa for this and wanted to do
this interpretation
and i think it's panned out wonderfully
so hey i mean it's like no cass and
jason mmo's been great
it's been awesome and it's such a
different take on aquaman
i'm very excited to see what zack snyder
does
with aquaman considering that like how
much people were so receptive to his
take on it not only justice league but
also
in freaking his aquaman solo movie made
over a billion dollars
you know so i'm like well now it's gonna
be cool to see
what zack snyder wanted to do fully with
him
in this first movie so i think there's a
lot to look forward to here and uh
i'm surprisingly getting a lot from
these one-minute clips other than just
cool images this is gonna be the new
mode of advertising i'm pretty sure
they're gonna go to like just reach a
couple seconds at a time and put a
couple of things you can really dive
into in those couple seconds and there
you go
yeah i love this man this was this was
this is wonderful there's a lot to think
about well guys leave your thoughts down
below
what'd you think one of the things we
didn't notice subscribe click the
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least
jn valente it's really easy for this one
i was looking through the list of the
people who get a patron of the day shout
out for the month of march and out of
anyone's profile pic
i was like who encompasses snyder cut
the best look at this right here
i'm gonna keep it really tiny on screen
because you know you didn't ask you if i
could share it
super tiny but look it's in black and
white the way zack snyder likes it you
got the beard like aquaman
if there was one image here of anyone's
profile pic at her patreon page
that belongs in the snyder cut this is
the only one
that would blend in so congratulations
zack snyder did a few reshoots
and you were one of them he was like we
need joker and batman to interact
and my friend jn that's what everyone
really wants look out for your own
solo trailer coming out with voices of
characters overlapping he's the big
cameo that zach's been teasing it's
going to be great i'm excited for it
spoilers thank you jane for being part
of my patreon page for so long love you
but appreciate all the support
[Music]